Please welcome Captain at the Texas
Department of Public Safety, John Miller.
All right, good morning everybody. My name is John
Miller. I'm a captain with the Texas Department of
Public Safety, Texas Ranger Division Special
Operations Group. We are an organization that
responds to critical man-made and natural
disasters across the entire state of Texas,
focusing on everything from border security
operations to hostage rescue events at the
tactical level and augmented by our border uh
border security operations center and joint
operation intelligence centers spread across the
uh Texas border at the operational and strategic
level. I'm going to be talking to you about the uh
runthrough of events leading up to the uh flooding
events on the 4th of July in Kirk County.
Two months ago today, in hours of darkness,
there was a massive storm system that gathered
over Kirk County and dropped a record amount of
rainfall in Kirk County. Specifically, the area up
river of Hunt, Texas, going through the South Fork
of the Guadalupe, really starting at Camp Mystic.
At the time period from midnight to 3:00 a.m.,
stream velocity rapidly increased in that area,
going from an average rate of about 50 gallons
a second through the South Fork flood gauges
that we have going up to in the next 3 hours
250 gallons per second. In the next 30 minutes,
that 250 gallons per second jumped to 125,000
gallons per second, which equates to about 10t of
flooding in the Kirk County area. However, in the
next 30 minutes, that rate increased from 125,000
gallons per second to 900,000 gallons per second,
making a storm system pass through the city of
Hunt, Ingram, Kurville, Centerpoint, crossing the
Kerr, Kendall County line into the city of Comfort
at approximately 1.7 million gallons per second.
That storm system continued its path of travel
through Kendall County going to the Kendall Kell
County line and continuing for an additional
27 miles before the Guadaloop River dumps into
Canyon Lake. With that, we had approximately
a 127mi area that we needed to work through.
And I want to say before I move forward that this
is all preliminary flood information as academics
and experts are still trying to make sense and
accurately model what happened on the flood event.
However, what we do know is that on the morning
of 4th of July, 39 children lost their lives in
the initial storm that came through. Those 39
uh children ranged in ages of 18 months to 18
years old. Additionally, with that, 80 adults
were lost. And making this extremely difficult
is the three primary loss sites that we had
during the flood event are all campgrounds
that were heavily populated due to the fact that
it was the 4th of July and people were trying to
get riverfront access to planned Fourth of July
activities in Kirk County. With that being said,
10 foot of flooding in Kirk County when we were
at the 125,000 gallons per second is somewhat
somewhat usual. Uh that area is prone to flooding.
There have been numerous flooding events. However,
this flooding event that came through the area
was truly truly off the records. I arrived in
uh Kurville on the 4th of July where I've been
in the uh incident command uh role for the entire
time. It's my first first two days away from there
and thank you Palunteer for the opportunity. So,
I'm going to talk about what happened uh before
my arrival on the day of the 4th. At around
4:00 a.m., local first responders and pre-stage
rescue elements uh activated in response to the
flood event. Inaccurate and impartial information
dominated the space when we first showed up. But
through systematic interviews with witnesses and
survivors, as well as listening to 911 emergency
calls, we were able to start reconstructing the
event. And understandably so with the impartial
and inaccurate information as a victim's sense
of time and space was greatly skewed by the sheer
terror of being in a life ordeath situation
mirrored with the fact that they were working
in torrential downpours unable to see other than
quick flashes of lightning that were going through
the area at 4:00 a.m. and uh completely unable
to notice anything except the audible and visual
signatures of being up on the second floor or
higher elevation of their houses, hearing victims
go by and cars with headlights on screaming for
help and uh trying to reconstruct what had taken
place around them. With that information that
we gathered from those survivors and through
teams on the ground reporting back information,
we're able to realize that the initial modeling
on flood levels that we got was was inaccurate and
flood levels had been on average 30 to 40 ft as it
was going through the South Fork AO. As that flood
continued through the South Fork and met with rock
faces and restricted terrain features, reflective
pressures pushed the flood waters up to as high as
84 feet in some places. And as that flood plane
opened up and came into the flood plane areas
near Kurville, Ingram and Centerpoint, pushed
out sometimes up to a mile from center line on
the river, taking destruction and debris with it.
Now, what we were able to do with that information
was start tracking and guiding the efforts of
first responders shown behind here uh shown shown
behind me in pink to uh direct their efforts
in our initial early phases of operation. As
geography and time increase in any critical event
management, specifically a multi-jurisdictional,
multi- agency response, we need to effectively
manage the distribution of figuring out victims,
survivors, and severe property damage across 127
river miles. The need to identify and inform these
locations was paramount and we needed a tool
set to accomplish all these system all these
tasks systematically without duplicating efforts
and avoiding circular reporting consistently.
The need for a consolidated common intelligence
and common operating picture was very apparent
during initial phases of the operation. The
DPS tax server and SAROP uh software that we're
using to track operations was very effective
initially. However, these two systems that
were the primary sources of information for
us were not consolidated, were not federated,
and were not able to ingest outside data feed
showing critical information that we needed.
For example, maintaining a single source where we
could track property damage, property locations,
and develop a system for granting and receiving
uh access from property owners uh to go onto
their properties and further assess the damage
and search for victims. through the event at the
end of that first week uh extremely chaotic
high volume of casualties uh coming through
the area we were able to uh finally be asked
by all local, state, and federal leadership,
what do you need to continue this colossal task
of finding these victims? To uh Dr. Karp's point,
I was one of those young special forces soldiers
working Afghanistan that had the fortunate
opportunity of utilizing Palunteer to inform where
my special forces team was operating. And I knew
that there was one answer to that question. We
needed assistance from Palunteer to build a common
operating picture that we would use to drive
future operations. DPS leadership requ uh received
that request for support. Contact was made between
DPS leadership, Mark Bennett, and Laya. And the
the ball started moving forward and getting
Palunteer out to Texas. We wrapped up our initial
conversations with Palunteer and that request for
support at about 7 or 5:00 p. a.m. local time back
in Texas. From there, the very next day, engineers
flew in from Washington DC, New York City,
and Rory, Jake, and Patrick joined my team on the
ground and were sitting next to me in that EOC by
11:00 a.m. With that, they built the entire Gaia
Foundry instance, you've been seeing behind me,
in less than 48 hours. As that 48 hour time period
passed and the instance was fully mission capable,
we began integrating other key stakeholders and
this platform became the center of gravity not
just for a sole agency but for the event overall
with input from our leadership team, ground units
and very critical and very useful injects from the
Palunteer team. We were able to cons consistently
improve and optimize the platform from that point
forward with every operational day to increase our
efficiency in the area of operation. We were able
to build in systems for indicators and warnings,
taking real-time stream information from USGS and
multiple other sources and monitor and utilize
that historic data and real-time variables
to develop something more than your standard
linear regression models and actually do time
series analysis and ARMA models to figure out
where we need to go next and develop a system for
what needed to happen as the uh as uh follow on
rain systems came through the area. As those
disperate but unified efforts be were able
to start visualizing the graphics that we had at
the micro messo and macrolevel unit of analyses,
we were able to begin generating statistical
analyses as well as predictive analysis for
future operational periods. That has allowed
us to synthesize maritime, ground, and aerial
sensors to direct maritime and ground teams in
their search efforts. The search strategy at this
point has been through multiple phases. Putting
our main search efforts at the highest probability
locations guided by uh spatial and temporal
analysis to place duplicative efforts at all
phases of the operation and be able through uh our
one of our chief investigators, Mr. Don Carter,
give the families accurate information about the
disposition of their loved ones during the event.
We were also able to develop a process of
cleaning that data, finding where uh where
we could give information to those families
and drive that effort forward even further
uh integrating in intelligence and investigative
functions within the team. Palanteer has support
us through all five phases of the operation.
Beginning with our hasty search through the area
coming 127 miles in a period of under three and a
half days with approximately 3,000 rescue efforts
that were in the area. We're able to generate and
manage target intelligence locations based off of
reporting back off multiple sensors going into
a very thorough maritime search of the entire
affected AO and leading to our final phase of
operation where we're working on geoysical data
collection sourced from synthetic aperture radar,
highdensity LAR, high density and highfidelity
uh visual uh imagery that's been captured.
overlay that with magnetometry, thermal scans,
and then use ground sensors with ground
penetrating radar, methane, and LAR to
figure out where victims are. So, in in giving
this presentation and saying everything that I've
said up here today, I'd like to close out firstly
by saying thank you to Dr. Karp and Palanteer.
uh before joining the military, before going into
college and grad school and find my way into DPS
and the Ranger Special Operations Group, I was
raised in Kurville, Texas, uh where my parents,
my grandparents still live and several close
family friends that were lost in the event. So
from Kurville and the citizens of Kirk County,
citizens of Texas, from the unified command,
from the search efforts that have been out there
at the local, state, and then national level as
well as the international searchers that have
come in to help us. Thank you for giving us the
unfair advantage as we continue this herculean
task of finding our last two victims of the 119
victims total. As we found 117 victims in record
time and uh really outside well above center mass
for an event like this, we are still not calling
this a victory as we still have two victims that
are unaccounted for. So to the families of those
victims, specifically to the the family of Mr.
Jeff Ramsay, father who is swept away with his
wife on the morning of the 4th, and Seal Stewart,
a beautiful young 8-year-old camper at Camp Mystic
that we're still looking for. To her parents,
Will and Cece, thank you for trusting us with this
most important mission that we've had. Thank you
for allowing us to bring in all these technology
sources to search for your loved one and giving us
the time and space to employ all these assets
to bring some resolution. We love you guys.
Thank you for trusting us and thank you
to all the people in this room for helping
us continue having that unfair advantage
and bring these last two home. Thank you.